-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
and now, we're going
to get to the news.
President Biden said on Friday
that he is "convinced"
that Russian
President Vladimir Putin
has already made the decision
to invade Ukraine.
Putin reportedly made
the decision somewhere around
his ninth birthday.
[ Laughter ]
He was a fun kid.
President Biden held a meeting
of the National Security Council
yesterday
to discuss the situation
in Ukraine,
where they told him
it's basically like
washing down Taco Bell
with an iced coffee --
we know something's going
to happen.
We just don't know when
and how bad.
[ Laughter ]
It was announced yesterday
that Britain's Queen Elizabeth
has tested positive
for the coronavirus.
Wow. You couldn't wait
just a few more weeks
to hit the club.
[ Laughter ]
The National Archives
confirmed last week
that former President Trump
improperly took
classified material
from the White House
to his Mar-A-Lago club.
Also, all the copper wiring.
[ Laughter ]
Ahead of President Biden's State
of the Union address next week,
authorities in Washington, D.C.
will reportedly put
additional fencing
around the Capitol,
which is actually all you need
to know
about the state of the union.
[ Laughter ]
Rudy Giuliani is set to appear
in an upcoming episode
of the singing competition show
"The Masked Singer."
I knew that couldn't be
his real face.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump
yesterday launched
his new social media app,
Truth Social.
It's expected to revolutionize
the way Americans
have their data stolen.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
22% percent of Americans said
that they are very interested
in being president of the
United States for one day.
"When can you start?"
asked one man.
[ Laughter ]
"'Cause I'd love if somebody
would jump in today."
[ Laughter and applause ]
A dog in California was recently
reunited with its family
after it was missing
for 12 years.
Or in the dog's mind,
a couple hours.
[ Laughter ]
"Everybody chill
the [bleep] out."
[ Laughter ]
"I went outside."
AT&T is set tomorrow
to shut down
its 3G cellular network.
As opposed to their 4G network,
which shuts down whenever.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
an athlete from Finland
told reporters over the weekend
that, after competing
in the men's 50-kilometer
cross-country ski race
at the Beijing Games,
his penis was
"a little bit frozen."
[ Laughter ]
Though, just because he needed
an excuse
after he was caught
"warming it up."
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!